bonjour laurent cesari merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors
comment analysez-vous la gestion des
manifestations par donald trump
je trouve que c'est assez électoralistes
ça me fait penser à sa gestion de la
crise du corona virus où il a incité ses
partisans à s'opposer ou un renard
démocrate qu'il voulait faire durer le
le confinement et là aussi il ya
nettement une je pense une volonté de se
distinguer de la dsv c'est l'adversaire
qui a pas l'air de très bien fonctionner
la guerre en ce moment avec le sondage
vous avez parlé est aussi ce qui est
tout à fait intéressant ce qui
m'intéressait c'est parce que vous avez
montré c'est lalush est un démocrate
chômeurs qui vont très bien
qu'effectivement le le le congrès où la
houle est là où la chambre et démocrate
va certainement lancer une bataille
juridique
et effectivement il ya la possibilité de
fermer une bataille juridique elle s'est
tenue les décisions de nos employés la
troupe peuvent être contestées juridique
floue que peut-on attendre du président
américain aujourd'hui pour essayer de
calmer cette crise pour câliner ça
serait bien difficile à dire haut ce que
c'est vraiment pas son style il a
toujours un style extrêmement clivant et
volontairement les connais tu mens je ne
peux pas vous répondre parce que j'avais
pour l'instant je ne l'imaginé pas
tentant de de la calmer je pense qu'il
va plutôt faire un peu comme comme
d'exxon en 1968 à savoir
continuez l'affrontement pour avec
l'espoir que la population se lasser des
émeutes et caetera et accès et accepte
une comment dire une bribe une
répression une répression plus sévère
mis à une différence quand même c'est
que nixon en 1968 il était candidat il
n'était pas président en poste
donc pour pour l'instant ça s'est il a
une stratégie qui lui coûtent quand vous
l'avez dit en matière électorale
c'est qu'il pense que ça va se retourner
ou si ça dure mais nous verrons et nous
sommes à cinq mois l'élection
présidentielle en pleine épidémie du
cours d'un virus cette crise sociale
peut-elle marque un tournant dans cette
campagne
alors je pense qu'effectivement ces
saynètes puisque bon de il ya un mois et
demi il y avait un léger avantage pour
patrice les sondages donnaient un léger
avantage pour bali d'elle mais on disait
encore bon c'est ses débuts c'est
maintenant la crise
la crise économique est vraiment sévère
vous avez 25 % de la population active
qui est inscrite au chômage
on a bien vu quand même que la politique
républicaine
ça consiste justement à faire à faire
cesser le bon cheminement au plus vite
de façon à ce que l'économie reprenne
mes cinq ça coûte aux entreprises
puisque les républicains se sont opposé
à des mesures comme ce que nous avons en
france les rennais qui facilite le
chômage les indemnisations chômage
partiel etc
il ya eu en groupe mille deux cent mille
deux cents dollars versés à chaque
citoyen pour solde de tout compte et là
maintenant le sondage du doigt le quai
dans le washington post on vous parlait
hier
vraiment impressionnant avec six mois je
regarde les chiffres à l'instant et
lectures de trump en 2016 qui maintenant
sont sombres seraient prêts à voter tron
40% et trop testant évangélique donc ce
qui est vraiment la base idéologique 30
27 % de 43
bonjour bon jeu est donc blanc avec 100
et plus d'universitaires trump 22% à 8 h
blanc avec études universitaires m 19
ryan 61 donc là il ya un retour le 5 on
sait pas comment dire comment ça va
s'arranger lancia que moi mais là il ya
une inflexion vraiment très très net
vous parliez du chômage et cette
question cette cette crise
sociopolitique est ce qu'on peut dire
qu'elle se limite à la question raciale
les inégalités sont elles quand même lié
à l'or il est certes les inégalités sont
liés
il est certain que les noirs sont
également les premiers touchés par la
crise du seven isna
parce que ce sont eux qui sont comme on
dit en france les les premiers secours v
et on voit bien que c'est les par
exemple à new york que ce sont les
quartiers noirs qui sont les plus
frappés par la part le par la maladie un
peu comme celle là la seine-saint-denis
ans
en france par exemple pour les non pas
pour des raisons de race mais pour des
raisons d'entassement sociale etc
alors que les les blancs ouvre
effectivement sont plus sont plus ruraux
et ils peuvent être effectivement où ils
sont - ils sont plus dispersées vont
peut-être moins - touché bien je vous en
prie merci merci laurent ses amis pour
pour toutes ces précisions vous rappelle
que vous êtes professeur d'histoire
contemporaine à l'université d'arras